biggie dit ce qui arrive à notre
ville pressé je ne sais pas c'est
comme si c'était la fin du monde c'est peut-être
Peter Parker comment diable vas-tu
la ville est en danger elle a besoin
de notre aide toute notre aide
très bien carla bley coach  gang un
costumé nutjobs démonte la ville
pièce par
pièce j'ai rendu la
pareille c'est une opportunité de frapper
tu sais plus tu te rapproches d'eux
plus tu deviens une
cible plus je me rapproche plus nous
avons de chances de les arrêter
je '  J'ai ordonné à Silver Sable et à son équipe
de vous tirer dessus à vue
cette ville en a assez de votre
vigilantisme
vous êtes officiellement un ennemi du peuple
allez Peter
[Musique]
comment je vous appelle je veux dire qui auriez-
vous comme un téléphone portable dans votre  dans vos
poches ou quelque chose
[Musique]
pour les joueurs que
vous